imaginemos que alguien está girando una
pelota de tenis envuelta en llamas atada
con una cadena y la está girando por
arriba de su cabeza digamos que la gira
con una velocidad constante ya hemos
descrito situaciones similares aunque no
tan dramáticas como esta pero podemos
visualizar los vectores de fuerza que
están actuando sobre la pelota en este
punto el vector velocidad lineal luce
así y esta es su magnitud v unos
momentos después cómo estará la pelota
pues estará por acá aún en llamas y aún
atada con la cadena pero cómo será su
vector velocidad suponiendo que tiene
una rapidez lineal constante la magnitud
del vector será la misma pero la
dirección ahora será tangente a la
trayectoria circular por lo que la
dirección ha cambiado una forma de
pensar en este cambio de dirección de la
velocidad que al principio nos puede
parecer poco intuitiva cuando pensamos
en la aceleración tendemos a verla como
el cambio en la magnitud de la velocidad
lineal pero el tener una magnitud
constante al mismo tiempo que existe un
cambio de dirección
implica necesariamente una aceleración
puede que al principio parezca poco
intuitivo pero imaginen que tomamos este
vector aceleración y lo ponemos acá con
el mismo punto de origen se verá más o
menos así vamos a dibujarlo con otro
color para que se note
estos dos vectores tienen la misma
longitud y son paralelos por lo que son
iguales si después de cierto tiempo el
vector velocidad cambia de estar así a
estar así el cambio neto en la velocidad
irá radialmente hacia adentro en otros
vídeos hemos hablado sobre el concepto
de aceleración centrípeta para mantener
algo en movimiento constante siguiendo
una trayectoria circular y para poder
cambiar la dirección del vector
velocidad tenemos que acelerarlo
radialmente hacia adentro esto es la
aceleración centrípeta aceleración hacia
adentro durante todos los instantes de
tiempo tenemos una aceleración hacia
adentro que denotamos con las letras
minúsculas para la magnitud de la
aceleración y con un subíndice se
minúscula para indicar que es centrípeta
a veces la veremos como
índice r radial pero en este contexto
usaremos centrípeta quizás se pregunten
lo siguiente desde que comenzamos a ver
la aceleración centrípeta qué pasa con
la primera ley de newton esta ley nos
dice que la velocidad de un objeto tanto
su magnitud como su dirección no cambian
a menos que una fuerza neta actúe sobre
el objeto aquí vemos sin lugar a dudas
que la dirección del vector velocidad
está cambiando por lo que la primera ley
de newton dice que hay una fuerza neta
que está actuando sobre esta pelota y
esa fuerza neta va a estar actuando en
la misma dirección que la aceleración
aquí vamos a presentar la idea de fuerza
centrípeta si un objeto está acelerando
hacia adentro
tendremos una fuerza centrípeta que está
causando la aceleración centrípeta efe
mayúscula subíndice c para indicar la
magnitud de la fuerza centrípeta y la
forma en la que estas dos se relacionan
es mediante la segunda ley de newton
aquí no tenemos nuevos tipos de fuerzas
son las mismas fuerzas que vemos siempre
en física sabemos que la fuerza
centrípeta es igual a la masa del objeto
por la magnitud de la aceleración
centrípeta si quieren podemos poner
flechas encima de estas variables para
indicar que son vectores conocemos la
dirección de la fuerza centrípeta y de
la aceleración centrípeta van hacia
adentro y que significa hacia adentro si
estas flechas van a tener diferente
dirección en cada instante de tiempo
bueno conceptualmente para cada posición
de la pelota sabemos hacia dónde será
adentro así pues la aceleración
centrípeta en la mecánica clásica no va
a aparecer de la nada la primera ley de
newton dice que si algo está acelerando
debe tener una fuerza neta actuando
sobre ese algo y si está acelerando
hacia adentro o mejor dicho en la
dirección centrípeta entonces la fuerza
neta también estará actuando hacia
adentro esto está relacionado con la
fórmula f igual a m por qué aprendimos
de la segunda ley de newton para
apreciar mejor esto traten de recordar
la última vez que giraron o rotaron una
pelota de tenis en llamas atada con una
cuerda por arriba de su cabeza para
poder mantener girando la pelota y que
no salga disparada
línea recta tenemos que seguir jalando
hacia adentro esta cadena y así la
pelota no salga disparada y golpe una
pared o incendia cosas ustedes
proporcionan la fuerza centrípeta para
mantener esta pelota de tenis en su
trayectoria circular uniforme nos vemos
en otro vídeo